the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
a lot of them don't even believe that
there's a war going on
on politics now fighting disinformation
from russia a local ukrainian woman and
unlv misinformation expert helps us sort
out what's true and what isn't
now
i'm
able to become the solution
towards that problem
fighting violence in our schools a group
of dads comes up with a program they
hope will keep students on the right
track
can las vegas ever actually
catch up to what is needed for
affordable housing well john i live and
hope
tackling affordable housing a local
nonprofit tells us what needs to happen
right now to address the need
[Music]
from eight news now
this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler we start
with filing season which is now underway
candidates can now formally enter races
for the 2022 election that includes two
of the most closely watched races in the
country nevada governor and senator
democratic governor steve silac was one
of the first people to put in his
paperwork for a second term there is a
packed republican primary to face him in
the general election ten gop candidates
say they will run against governor
sisilak that includes clark county
sheriff joe lombardo former senator dean
heller and north las vegas mayor john
lee governor sisolak says his focus will
be on high paying jobs
i want jobs to pay more than the minimum
wage and you can support yourself
because with the price of food and the
price of housing and the price of
gasoline you can't get by minimum wage
the filing period ends march 18th the
primary election june 14th
there's an interesting republican
primary primary taking shape up in state
senate district 17. that's the area
around fallon east of reno carson city
current assembly minority leader robin
titus who you see there she's now
running for the seat so is former
assembly minority leader jim wheeler
it's currently held by senate minority
leader james settlemeyer who's terming
out
interestingly the person who held
wheeler's assembly seat before him was
also james settlemyre
now to the ongoing russian invasion of
ukraine both nations met for peace talks
this week in turkey but there was no
breakthrough now the map you see behind
me here that shows cities in ukraine
that are currently under attacking sea
kharkiv maripole and of course the
capital of kiev now in mariopol that is
where there are efforts right now to
establish a humanitarian corridor the
world health organization says there
have been at least 18 attacks on health
care facilities u.s officials are
concerned russia could use chemical or
biological weapons but then accuse the
west of actually using them
we have seen one of their playbooks is
to accuse the other
that which you are doing or what you
plan to do
a senior defense official tells cbs news
russia could encircle the capital kyiv
in another one to two weeks the u.s
estimates as many as five to six
thousand russian forces have already
been killed in action that's in addition
to the thousands of ukrainian soldiers
and civilians who have died
many ukrainians have expressed surprise
some of their russian relatives don't
believe civilians are under attack i
spoke with mary blankenship she's from
ukraine she's also a researcher at
unlv's brookings west and a specialist
in online disinformation and
misinformation
the disinformation misinformation that
we're seeing
is widespread and is also evolving
as the conflict progresses in the
beginning of the invasion what you
mostly saw are doctored videos
either old videos or digitally enhanced
videos
like for example from previous russian
parades or even from video games
made to look like the ukrainian army is
getting decimated and that the main
purpose of that disinformation was meant
to intimidate the russian forces and the
russian people into capitulating and
surrendering to the russian forces but
as we're seeing this war progress and
we're seeing the defiance
and the courage of the ukrainian people
russia is not winning and the
disinformation is becoming more and more
unhinged
so right now the the most
the greatest
disinformation that is spreading
has to do
with for example the threat of
bioweapons that russia is claiming
ukraine is having or
even the continuation
that ukraine is filled with a bunch of
nazis yeah and which was sort of one of
the things that russian president putin
sort of said at the very beginning is
one of the motivations you're ukraining
yourself and you know we've done some
interviews with people who have family
in russia and
you know most people are sympathetic to
what's going on for the ukrainians but
there are some people who seem to
believe what is being said by the
russian government
is the
the misinformation and the propaganda
that you're seeing from the russian side
working
for based on what you're seeing online
on twitter and reactions and so forth i
mean is it working for like the russian
people yeah is it is it is it changing
hearts and minds
well i i don't necessarily know if it's
changing hearts and minds but it's
probably solidifying what the people if
they are supporting putin they will
continue support including
uh let me give you kind of
the the what the current situation is in
russia right now uh instagram is blocked
facebook and twitter is blocked vpns are
illegal
independent russian-based and
foreign-based media outlets have also
been banned and so really the only
access that
russian citizens have is to
russian-sponsored uh state-sponsored
media specific to nevada
what you're seeing online does it stand
out to you does it concern you are you
surprised by what you're seeing
i'm a little bit surprised that it's not
other types of disinformation of like
around the world the one that is most
popular is that ukraine is filled with a
bunch of nazis right then they there
really are russia is really is trying to
denouncify ukraine that's kind of the
most popular claim so
um it is surprising to me that the
disinformation and misinformation that
is most perpetuated in nevada is not on
such an emotional level
um but in a sense it doesn't
it makes sense uh the kind of
disinformation especially looking at
from a domestic viewpoint that this is a
distraction from like domestic issues
that are going on
blankenship suggests if you see
disinformation don't interact with it do
your research but interacting can help
it spread more
meanwhile nevada senator jackie rosen
gave a floor speech this week calling
for more security assistance to ukraine
nevadans agree that we can't sit idly by
as putin continues to terrorize
terrorize the ukrainian people
the horrific images that the world has
seen
they require action
they require action
we cannot sit idly by and do nothing
so that speech was in support of a 14
billion dollar assistant package to
ukraine would also step up sanctions on
russia's economy the measure passed
the effects of war abroad are certainly
being felt here at home every day we're
all seeing new records in gas prices
here in southern nevada it's gone up
about 10 cents per day you can see
friday the average
price for an average gallon of regular
gas was 4.93 and that could top five
dollars by monday diesel also very
expensive you can see or crack the five
dollar gallon mark this week here in las
vegas it's 527 nevada has the second
highest gas prices in the country right
now
high gas prices but also ties in with
our record inflation federal data for
february shows rates hit a 40-year high
while the white house says the ukraine
conflict is fueling that surge capitol
hill republicans aren't buying the
excuse raquel martin reports from
washington
this is a national emergency republican
senators say americans are reeling from
skyrocketing prices from the grocery
store to the gas pump new data shows
last month annual inflation climbed to
7.9 percent a 40-year high bacon is as
expensive as filet mignon used to be at
a thursday press conference midwest
republicans like south dakota senator
john thune and nebraska senator deb
fischer blame president biden for the
spike it's due
to the administration's policy they say
one way to help is by promoting
corn-based ethanol fuel from u.s farmers
are readily available to displace
russian oil at this point the white
house isn't answering calls to expand
the use of ethanol and says americans
should expect fuel prices to continue to
rise we also believe it will be
temporary thursday press secretary jim
sake insisted the white house is doing
everything it can to bring down prices
including coordinating a coordinated
release from the strategic petroleum
reserve to ensure we're increasing
supply but says russia's invasion of
ukraine creates new challenges meanwhile
democrats like ohio senator sherrod
brown are calling for more aggressive
action to ensure big oil isn't unfairly
marking up crisis we're working on
legislation that would do
that would tax excess profits in the oil
industry and they're huge and plow that
money back into people's pockets there's
also growing calls to launch a federal
gas tax holiday but many republicans say
the best solution is expanding u.s oil
production
in washington raquel martin
nevada congressman dina titus the
democrat is asking the federal trade
commission to look into those
allegations of gas price gouging in a
letter to the ftc she highlights some
examples from around the country of gas
stations charging 33 percent more than
their competitors one in north carolina
for example charged 10 dollars a gallon
however the congresswoman did not cite
any examples of price gouging here in
las vegas
next on politics now stopping violence
in our schools
i believe that with our presence there
people's lives can be changed
how a group of dads are trying to
inspire students to behave in class
plus a big ruling for ballot initiatives
that would raise education taxes we'll
look at whether you're going to actually
see them on the ballot in november
you're never far from findlay
welcome back to politics now
two big ballot initiatives to raise
taxes for state education can now be
pulled from the ballot one would have
raised the state's gaming tax rate to
nearly 50 percent another would have
added another one and a half percent to
our sales tax after gathering more than
double the signatures needed the
teachers union in the state says it's
going to abandon the initiatives
secretary of state barbara sagavski
first said that those measures had to
stay on the ballot for 2022 but this
week a carson city judge ruled the union
can go forward and abandon those
initiatives
violence in schools once again the talk
at this week's clark county school board
meeting solutions and future plans were
laid out and they include potentially an
increase in school police staffing
expanding current programs and enhancing
student discipline but one parent still
wants more done
how many times we've seen the school
district have these meetings and then we
have them again and nothing happens we
have all the casinos entertainment
capital but yet our children are being
left behind basically
one parent's opinion a four hundred
thousand dollar grant was also approved
to allow police and social workers to
organize at-home visits for at-risk
students
a local group is offering another
solution now you may have caught a
glimpse before of a group here on
channel 8 the program behind me here
it's a story from cbs news that went
viral it profiled a louisiana group
called dads on duty a group of fathers
walk school halls and support students
and also prevent violence as the 8 news
now i-team's vanessa murphy tells us the
same effort could come to ccsd
i came from a broken household my mom
raised me with my sister in christian
garcia's words he was a problem back
when he was a student at western high
school in las vegas but now
i'm
able to become the solution
towards that problem now a dad himself
he wants to go back to school in a
different way i believe that with our
presence there
people's lives can be changed that's
through a new group founded by community
leader troy martinez called dads in
schools for those students that don't
have two parents those students that
don't have the support at home they'll
at least have some opportunity to have
that when they go to school let's go he
says he was inspired by dads on duty
from louisiana let's make it to class my
son after seeing this cbs news story he
connected with them just the presence of
dads of fathers of men
being at the school campus decreased
almost it completely erased the fighting
and violence on school campuses from
august to february the district reports
more than 6 100 calls for police at
schools the top three issues harassment
or threats fights and assaults or
batteries the cry is there they need our
help and
men in this community will and are
standing up to make that cry in the
fifth largest school district in the
nation this is no easy task but martinez
says as a grandfather of 11 at ccsd he
is passionate we have powerful teachers
and they're making impacts
on these students lives but what we need
to see is that staff and the students
have a safe
learning environment if approved by the
board to reflect to the students and
staff that were there to be neutral
you'll see men in uniforms like this
walking school halls we're not the
police we are not the school
administration he promises no
punishments and no lectures just support
and just like in louisiana
a few laughs
we're going to try
vanessa murphy live local now the
solution if you're interested in
learning more about this we do have a
link over at 8newsnow.com martinez says
volunteers do have to go through
background checks there's a vetting
process and training before taking part
also in the school district see three
ccsd board seats are up for grabs this
year trustee president irene cepeda has
already filed to run again danielle
ford's seat is also up for re-election
and so is her board rival linda cavazos
however neither of them have filed to
run again just yet
next on politics now finding affordable
housing
what can be done today to try and at
least make this the smallest of dents in
the crisis of affordable housing
vouchers vouchers vouchers
vouchers coming up we will break down
what affordable housing means why we
have so little of it and possible
solutions from the local
vegas strong walker furniture
you're watching politics now
with home prices and rents at record
levels there's a push in nevada for more
affordable housing so we have some
questions first what is affordable
housing well clark county and nevada
essentially define it as housing where
the person living in the home is paying
no more than 30 percent of their gross
income for housing costs that would
include utilities now for a person who
makes about 40 000 a year that would be
a thousand dollars per month for rent
and utilities here in clark county there
are 17 thousand just a little more than
that seventeen thousand rental units
that meet the definition right now of
affordable housing another seventeen
hundred more than that or so are uh
already under in progress so seventeen
thousand existing seventeen hundred in
progress is this enough well no i spoke
with audra hammernick with nevada hand
it's a nonprofit dedicated to creating
affordable housing we spoke about this
issue
what is the need right now
so the need right now the number from
the national low-income housing tax
credit coalition is 84 000 unit need for
affordable rental units in southern
nevada actually the entire state of
nevada when i got here in 2019 that
number was 79 000. so in two years it's
increased by 5000 units
and we talked about how things are
getting expensive here uh price of rent
price of homes everything is becoming
more expensive is that the driving
factor there's just more people that
can't afford to live here anymore
literally i think that's part of it i
think that we're a
state that's seeing lots of people move
to nevada which is terrific on the other
hand we have a housing shortage whether
it's in the affordable market or just
the entire housing market so all of that
pressure is just building up into higher
cost so let's talk about the the state
of play from a political standpoint but
also just from a non-profit advocacy
standpoint what is being done right now
from nevada hand and others to try and
meet the need aside from just simply
building more homes uh it's really
building more that's all it is
more troublesome right um we are
right now have 700 units under
construction
when our staff here is 84 000 we you
know we're really proud about that 700
but we know it's a drop in the bucket
and the need is so great we're getting 2
000 phone calls a day to our agency we
serve 8 000 people right now we have 35
different apartment communities 4 600
units and it's not even close to being
enough
is there any solution that can be
tackled or any solution that's out there
that doesn't involve quite simply just
building
home building units building complexes
in las vegas is there ways to use what
exists
and sort of retrofit it to the need in
our community i think there's two things
one is what you're talking about the uh
adaptive reuse is what we call that in
the housing world where you're taking
maybe
a bank that's not being used anymore and
rehabbing that into affordable housing
sometimes it works really well and
sometimes it doesn't it's very expensive
to build
bathrooms and kitchens and that's what
ends up being apartment units so it's
possible and um some of those things um
take a long time too just because it's a
zoning use change in the same way that
we might need that on the new
construction side the second thing that
i mentioned is we're really
happy and proud about the southern
nevada regional housing authority their
board of commissioners hired a stand-up
new executive director
he's his name's louis jordan he's
talking publicly about creating a
project-based section 8 program and that
is the other thing that could really
help move the needle on affordable
housing because adding that voucher
component to buildings gives people more
purchase power in the rental market
we're also working with senator cortez
masto's office
to get just more vouchers into nevada
when you look at some of the
eastern cities that had higher
populations that are losing folks and
then you look at nevada when we're
deeply growing
the hud formula just simply is not fair
it's saying that
what you got last year vouchers is what
you're going to get now and it's it's
there's an inequity there and we're
going to really try hard to get more of
those vouchers can las vegas ever
actually
catch up to what is needed for
affordable housing
well john i live in hope
i think that
it's going to be rough because we have
some really big numbers right 84 000
units is a lot of units
but the
american rescue plan act dollars that
are funds that are coming in the state
has dedicated 500 million for affordable
housing
300 plus
million just on the multi-family side
which is great the county has dedicated
150 million
pair those with 9 tax credits and you
can build a lot of units is it going to
get you 84 000 not even close
hammer nick says it takes about 18
months for a new affordable housing unit
to come online
through monday at walker
[Music]
this week in what to watch the filing
deadline it ends this week we're keeping
an eye out to see if anybody switches
races or maybe drops out at the last
minute so we will take a look at how
some of the races for the state
legislature will shape up we'll have
that we'll also take a closer look at
clark county school district what's
going on there and have a closer look at
everything politics that is happening
across the state hopefully you'll join
us for that north las vegas very
competitive series of races we'll take a
closer look
all that information online as well
8newsnow.com politics now is back next
saturday thank you very much for
watching we'll see you then